In 2005, investors were euphoric about the booming housing market.
Financial institutions raked in billions of dollars financing real estate ventures.
Riding the wave of financial success.
But then, the wave broke, and it all came crashing down.
1 in 10 Americans couldn’t afford their mortgage.
Nearly 10 million Americans
lost their homes to foreclosure.
Housing prices fell 30% from their highs, and in
big cities like Miami, they dropped around 40%.
The result was the worst global economic
crisis since the Great Depression.
Yet despite the disaster, one trader triumphed.
John Paulson predicted the
housing market would collapse.
He bet against it even when
other investors laughed him off.
And here’s the thing - Paulson didn’t
know a thing about real estate.
He was an expert in mergers and acquisitions.
Yet during the market meltdown, when
other firms lost billions of dollars,
he made $20 billion for
his firm and his clients.
That's why it's called the greatest trade ever.
This is the story of how an outsider
pulled off the greatest trade of all time.
Before the crisis unfolded, John
Paulson was a small fish in a big pond.
In 2005, his funds only gained 5%, below
the average of 9% at other hedge funds.
At age 49, he was also older than many of
his peers who were in their 20s and 30s.
He had catching up to do because
after attending NYU and Harvard
Business School, he went into consulting first.
But he soon realized he’d rather make money for
himself than advise others on how to make money.
So, he got a job at investment bank
Bear Stearns and then Gruss where he
gained valuable experience and
also partied hard after hours.
Despite rising through the ranks, he sensed
that greater opportunities lay ahead.
In 1994, he started his own
hedge fund, Paulson & Co.
Trouble is, the phone didn’t ring.
No one wanted to invest with him.
As Paulson recounted to Gregory Zuckerman in his
book, “The Greatest Trade Ever, “It was hard to
be rejected; it was a lonely period. After a while
I said, this is too much. He lifted my spirits.”
Referring to his dad.
Paulson also clung to Winston Churchill’s
famous “never give up” commencement speech.
Since no one took a chance on him, he
decided to take a chance on himself.
He started his firm with $2
million of his own money.
It took him a full year to find his first client.
He barely had enough resources to hire employees,
though he did hire an assistant, Jenny
Zaharia, who would later become his wife.
In the 1990s, his firm managed
tens of millions of dollars,
whereas the big hedge funds
managed hundreds of millions.
But the events of nine eleven would
change the trajectory of his firm.
In response to the shock and uncertainty,
the Federal Reserve cut interest
rates to try to stimulate the economy.
This made borrowing cheaper, including for
mortgages, allowing more people to afford homes.
Yet this inadvertently laid the
groundwork for the housing crisis.
Banks and other mortgage lenders started
loosening their standards, offering
mortgages even to those with poor credit.
“If you were a borrower and you had no credit,
you had a horrible credit rating, you had
a history of never paying your money back
and you had no cash to put down to buy the
house, they would still lend you 110% of
the purchase price of the house. So you
can actually buy the house with no money
down and get 10% of the purchase price in
your pocket, as crazy as that may sound.
By 2005, 24% of all mortgages required
no down payment, up from 3% in 2001.
These risky loans, known as subprime mortgages,
were appealing to lenders due
to their higher interest rates.
Banks packaged these subprime mortgages into
bundles and sold them to investment banks like
Lehman Brothers and Merrill Lynch which converted
these bundles into mortgage-backed securities,
selling them to a range of investors worldwide,
from Japanese pension funds to Swiss banks.
When an increasing number of homeowners
couldn’t afford their mortgage payments,
leading to widespread defaults, it
triggered a domino effect through
the financial system, which
experts failed to foresee.
According to Moody’s and S&P, there had
never been a default of an investment-grade
mortgage-backed security. Never being I guess
post-WWII or post-1950. And we said, ‘Oh well,
they did default in the Great Depression.’
They said, ‘Well, unless you think we’re gonna
have a Great Depression, we don’t think mortgage
securities are gonna default.’ And they laughed.
But Paulson didn’t think the past would predict
the future given the risky
mortgages being issued.
The only thing that kept these mortgages afloat
was that housing prices were rising rapidly.
If you couldn’t pay your mortgage and defaulted,
the lender would take back the house, but would
still profit as the property value went up.
But what would happen if
housing prices started to fall?
Paolo Pellegrini wondered the same.
He had asked Paulson for a job
after his career had derailed,
convinced that his Italian accent had hurt him.
Pellegrini poured over mountains of
housing data and noticed a troubling trend:
Home prices had increased an average of 1.4%
between 1975 to 2000 factoring in inflation
but afterward, soared 7% a year on average
from 2000 to 2005, hinting at a bubble.
His analysis also showed that when
housing prices fell in the past,
they dropped below the trend line, suggesting when
the housing market corrected, it would be brutal.
He and Paulson viewed the housing
market as a house of cards,
bound to collapse when housing prices fell.
It was kind of a very simple physics problem. If
home prices kept falling and went negative and
delinquencies kept rising, at some point the
mortgage market would collapse and then these
mortgages would sustain losses. It became very
obvious to us but the problem is, the machinery,
the factories that were just geared up to
buy mortgages, securitizing and selling them,
they just were oblivious to what was
going on. They couldn’t stop the machine.”
Pellegrini proposed that they bet against risky
mortgages by purchasing credit-default swaps.
Credit-default swaps - or CDS - acted like
insurance on mortgage-backed securities.
It’s like buying insurance for a house.
If the house catches on fire (which can be
compared to default on the mortgage-backed
security), the insurance company, or the seller
of the credit-default swap, compensates the buyer.
The cost of insurance was only around
1% of the amount being protected.
For example, it cost $10 million annually to
ensure $1 billion of mortgage-backed securities.
If their bet didn’t go well,
they’d lose $10 million.
But if the securities defaulted,
they’d get $1 billion.
In essence we risked 1% in order to make
100% if they defaulted within the average
timeline of these CDS which was about
two years. So it was a very skewed trade
where you lost little if the trade didn’t
work but you made a lot if it did work.
Understanding credit-default swaps
required specialized knowledge.
Pellegrini educated himself through tutorials
provided by Bear Stearns brokers
and also at industry conferences.
Their strategy involved targeting the
riskier mortgage-backed securities.
Mortgage-backed securities are divided into
different layers or slices, known as tranches.
Each tranche has a different level of risk.
The top tranches like AAA are considered
the safest, the bottom ones the riskiest.
Paulson strategically targeted BBB slices,
believing that a housing collapse would impact
BBB-rated tranches more than the “safer” A ones.
His firm bought $25 billion worth of
credit-default swaps with all the major banks.
The total value insured was substantial
even with only a 1% annual premium.
Paulson established a new
fund dedicated to betting
against subprime mortgages on a large scale.
However, finding investors was difficult
because few believed in his strategy.
As described in Zuckerman’s book,
Jeffrey Tarrant of the hedge fund
Protégé Partners said, “People on
trading desks warned, ‘He (Paulson)
doesn’t have expertise in the area,’
or ‘He doesn’t know what he’s doing’.”
A Bear Sterns expert said: “You guys need to
do more research on historical
price appreciation.” - page 155
When Paulson asked, “What
are your models based on?”
The expert replied: “Our models are fine.
We’ve been doing this for 20 years.”
Paulson found himself bewildered by
the lack of interest in his fund.
He lamented, “I don’t know why they don’t
get it…this is the trade of a lifetime.”
He ended up scrounging together $147 million
for his new fund, mostly from friends.
There were other traders who foresaw a collapse,
but they weren’t as determined as
Paulson and didn’t invest nearly as much.
Unlike Paulson, Michael Burry failed to convince
investors to support a dedicated fund for betting
against subprime mortgages. When investors started
withdrawing money from his firm, he reluctantly
began to sell his credit-default swaps. Despite
scoring half a billion in gains for his firm,
he wondered what might have been if he hadn't
been forced to sell some of his positions early.
Andrew Lahde’s boss was furious at his
bearish housing bets and fired him.
So he set up his own hedge fund and
earned $100 million for his clients,
and $10 million for himself.
When he retired, he wrote a
letter sticking it to those
who failed to see the warning signs of a crash:
"I was in this for the money.
The low-hanging fruit, i.e., idiots
whose parents paid for prep school,
Yale, and then the Harvard
MBA, was there for the taking."
Greg Lippmann at Deutsche Bank played a
crucial role in facilitating credit-default
swap contracts for Paulson. Lippmann's
own bets against housing were successful,
but the troubles at his bank meant he
was only given a few million as a bonus.
Paulson had encouraged his friend,
real-estate millionaire Jeffrey Greene
to invest in his fund, but Greene decided to
secure credit-default swap contracts on his own,
which Paulson viewed as a stab in
the back.
Greene pocketed $500 million on his bets.
Although all of these investors
walked away very wealthy,
none matched the scale of Paulson’s earnings.
Paulson went all in, certain
everything would collapse.
In addition to shorting mortgage-backed
securities, his team also shorted banks
that had large quantities of subprime
mortgages: New Century, Fannie Mae,
Freddie Mac, Citibank, Washington Mutual,
IndyMac, Bear Stearns, Lehman Brothers.
Paulson’s top trader, Brad
Rosenberg, summed it up this way:
“We had to get on as many trades as
possible before it was too late.”
The wait, however, seemed endless.
By late 2006, the housing market was slowing down,
yet the widespread mortgage defaults
they anticipated hadn’t yet occurred.
The main obstacle was the role of
Collateralized Debt Obligations (CDOs).
These complex financial products
which bundled various types of debt
including mortgage-backed securities
masked the true risks in the market.
They were like the sturdier lower
blocks of a tower about to fall over,
delaying the inevitable collapse.
Paulson reassured his concerned wife, Jenny,
saying, “It’s just a matter of waiting.”
The collapse began in late 2006 when New Century,
one of the largest subprime mortgage lenders,
reported an unexpected loss as its
borrowers struggled to pay their loans.
In 2007, two big hedge funds run by Bear
Sterns that were heavily invested in
subprime mortgage-backed securities
imploded, triggering market chaos.
The heads of Citigroup and
Merril Lynch were ousted.
And then, in September 2008,
Lehman Brothers went under,
the largest bankruptcy in U.S. history that
sent shockwaves through the financial system.
The U.S. government stepped in to rescue
the government-sponsored enterprises,
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac,
guaranteeing over $300 billion
of debt, motivated by a desire
to stabilize the housing market.
The fallout from the financial
crisis was devastating:
10 million American homeowners faced foreclosure,
unemployment soared, and retirement savings and
investments plummeted as the stock market
fell 60%. (from fall 2007 to early 2009)
And yet, in the turmoil, Paulson
saw an unprecedented opportunity,
and it changed his life.
Paulson & Co. earned $15 billion in 2007,
with Paulson himself making $4 billion. Over
the next two years, his firm added another $5
billion, with Paulson taking home $2 billion.
He was no longer a mediocre
player but a Wall Street legend.
Paolo Pellegrini, who was often overshadowed by
Paulson, was rewarded with $175 million in 2007.
The possibility that we’re in another
housing bubble is a topic of debate.
The financial crisis led to significant
regulatory changes like stricter lending
standards to try to avert another disaster.
Yet, despite these measures,
future bubbles can’t be ruled out.
Financial markets are complex and
influenced by a wide range of factors,
including economic policies, market
conditions, and investor behavior.
John Paulson’s story is a powerful reminder of the
value of in-depth analysis and independent
thinking, even when few believed him.
Sometimes, the most insightful decisions
are those that go against the grain.
Smart financial choices start with the right
trading platform, and Moomoo stands out.
Moomoo is a trading app with ZERO commission
on trading stocks, ETFs, and options.
What I really like about Moomoo is its
very user-friendly interface that
has all the information you need.
It can visually present to you everything from
individual stock chart trends
to company financial data.
For example, I wanted to learn about John
Paulson's latest moves, so I located his firm,
Paulson & Co., and discovered that he
added 2.8 million shares of gold stocks.
It’s not a bad way to copy “homework”
from professional investors!
In certain markets, moomoo
offers a Cash Sweep Program
where the money you haven’t
invested can earn interest.
In the U.S., new users have
a limited-time opportunity to
earn 5.1% APY plus an extra 3% APY,
along with up to 15 free stocks.
Don't miss out on this exciting
offer available until February 29th.
And good news for Canadians – moomoo has launched
its RRSP/TFSA accounts just in time for the
RRSP contribution deadline on February 29th.
You can start by contributing
as little as $100 to your RRSP
or TFSA account and receive $50 in cash rewards
with the potential to accumulate up
to $1,500 in cash rewards.
In Australia, just by signing up, you
can earn a fantastic 6.8% p.a. interest
for the first 180 days, plus score up to
10 free stocks with eligible deposits.
And if you're worried about fund safety, don't be.
Your funds are backed by $1
million of FDIC insurance,
offering the same security as traditional banks.
Start making smarter financial choices today
by signing up for moomoo with my
custom link in the description.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.